national treasure spoke to the hearts
and minds of many a young history
enthusiasts and action-thriller fans
everywhere when it hit theaters in 2004
the box office smash featured Nicolas
Cage as Ben gates and Explorer who
steals the Declaration of Independence
in his quest to find a hidden treasure
a sequel national treasure book of
secrets was released in 2007 and
improved on the first film's box-office
return talk about a third film started
shortly after and although rumors have
persisted over the years nothing has
come of those stories
unfortunately for fans of the franchise
production appears to have stalled on
the third film here's why it's unlikely
the Disney will ever actually release
national treasure three busy producer
famed producer Jerry Bruckheimer is the
man behind many of your favorite action
franchises including Beverly Hills Cop
bad boys and Pirates of the Caribbean
Jerry Bruckheimer films was also one of
the production companies that worked on
the national treasure series but that
might be what's holding up a potential
third film Bruckheimer said that he's
still looking to quote get this thing
going in reference to the third film but
right now his plate is pretty full with
his work on long awaited sequels for
some of his other popular franchises
these films include bad boys for life a
third installment in the bad boy series
he's also working on a Tom Cruise led
Top Gun sequel titled Top Gun maverick
which is slated for a 2019 release with
so many other movies of waiting his
attention
Bruckheimer likely doesn't have much
time to devote to national treasure
three fact-checking
the national treasure films may not be
the most historically accurate to ever
grace the big screen but apparently
quite a lot of research still goes into
making them and that could be part of
what's delayed national treasure 3 for
so long as Cage revealed in 2016 it's
been a challenge getting the script
where it needs to be thanks to the
unique constraints of the franchise he
told Entertainment Weekly I do know that
those scripts are very difficult to
write because there has to be some
credibility in terms of the facts and
fact-checking because it was relying on
historical events and then you have to
make it entertaining
there's thousands of years of world
history down there and it belongs to the
world jon turteltaub who's directed both
films and is attached to the third also
said script issues have been plaguing
the film telling Collider in 2013 it's
so damn hard to write a great historical
mystery based on fact turteltaub said at
the time that he thought they'd be
shooting the film within two years but
it appears that getting the script just
right has been a longer process than he
anticipated critical aversion critical
success isn't always tied to box-office
success and the national treasure
franchise is a perfect example of that
principle in action the franchise has
even earned a number of nominations at
the Golden Raspberry Awards honoring the
worst hollywood has to offer including a
worst actor nod for cage for book of
secrets the fact that critics were never
on board with the franchise could be
something that has deterred the studio
from ordering another movie the failing
critical and box office returns of other
franchises like transformers and Pirates
of the Caribbean hint that reviews to
matter and making another film in a
franchise that's already earned critics
ire could be too great a risk
cages decline the national treasure
franchise managed to improve its grosses
from the first film to the second but
Nicolas Cage has been seeing his box
office returns fall for quite some time
now
aside from his Ghost Rider franchise
kick-ass and his voice role in the
Croods cage has led a series of
commercial flops in recent years which
could make the studio reluctant to rely
on him as a leading man once again cage
has reportedly been taking roles left
and right the past decade to help him
pay off his debts which could explain
his string of smaller films financial
need may be enough to get him back to
the franchise but the studio could be
leery of signing a star whose box office
appeal is in question Disney's
priorities a lot has changed for Disney
since book of secrets at theaters in
2007 while the studio was never a minor
player in the movie marketplace their
info
has been stepped up significantly in the
past few years mostly thanks to major
moves in picking up Marvel and Lucasfilm
since the last national treasure was
released Disney gained a lot more
franchises to work with and they're not
slowing down they don't need to go back
to a franchise that's been in limbo for
a decade changing landscape a solid
franchise used to be a guarantee that
audiences would turn out for a movie but
the box office has changed a lot in
recent years recent franchises that have
seen diminishing returns at the box
office include Bruckheimer's Pirates of
the Caribbean movies the Transformers
franchise Tom Cruise's The Mummy and
Dwayne Johnson's Baywatch while there
are a few high-profile exceptions
including Marvel's continued box-office
dominance it's risky to assume national
treasure would be one of them which
could be just one more reason Disney
won't release national treasure 3 thanks
for watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]